hello everybody thank you for being here
it's very exciting to see so many people
interested in genetics at the software
conference that's definitely very
unusual but very cool so genetics is a
vertical field for a software engineer
to be in my name is Miro Tupac I spent
my days at DNA stack which is a Canadian
company where we're building a cloud
bottom for genomics and I spent my
nights with a nonprofit organization
that's called the Global Alliance for
genomics and health which is basically a
standards body in genetics
it's a coalition of over 500
institutions at this point institutions
from research life sciences IT health
care disease advocacy you name it
basically organizations working together
on standardizing how genetic data is
stored processed and most importantly
shared so I'm here today to talk about a
particular project that I've been
working on under the umbrella of this
organization and it's sort of a
pioneering effort in genetic data
sharing the project we're talking about
is called the beacon Network and it's an
open source project that it's very dear
to me something I'm very passionate
about because I really do believe that
data sharing or lack thereof is one of
the most pressing issues in genetics
right now genomics is a comparative
science when you want to analyze the
data you typically want to take your
data and look at it in the context of
ideally as many other samples as you can
and a very common problem with
researchers face is actually just not
having enough data it's not necessarily
that the data doesn't exist sometimes
quite often actually the data has been
collected it just hasn't been made
accessible so data sharing really is the
key to advancing biomedicine and
ultimately improving healthcare the
beacon network is one of the first
successful initiatives with this focus
at least at the global scale the project
started about four years ago as my
Google Summer of Code project actually
and then got some fraction became a
master's thesis and now I'm actually
fortunate enough to still be working on
this so I'm definitely very biased so
much for the disclaimer so why are we
talking about this besides the fact that
I enjoy speaking about this well to our
knowledge this is the largest search and
discovery engine of human genetic
mutations in the world which is pretty
cool
and when I say like this the largest
search engine you're probably thinking
that the kind of issues that women
dealing with are issues around
performance or scalability and I would
be lying if I said that we never hit any
of those issues with it but the biggest
issue for us was actually
standardization like I said g4j is a
standards body and from the very
beginning this was developed as kind of
a driving force behind a standard and
basically an application on top of a
standard so just getting the right
people together getting them to agree on
things and developing this as a standard
that was the really hard part for us but
I think the fact that this is in
genomics that's one of the more
successful data sharing initiatives
there and then this that it was
developed as a volunteering effort on a
global scale is such an
interdisciplinary environment I think
all these things make it a pretty
interesting case study so let's start by
taking a look at the system and I will
try to do live demo here if my
connection is ok so if you go to beacon
- network dark you will see a screen
like this that's sort of the main
deployment of the service there's a
couple of things going on here there's a
search field there's a list of
participating organizations some press
coverage links to documentation etc but
the cool part is really this search
field here and we call this a search
engine here and you can search for this
application but maybe a better term
would be discovery engine because the
discovery part discovering where the
mutations are is actually the main use
case for this service so in this search
field I can specify the gentle mutation
I'm just going to select the really
well-known one here it's something that
has been associated with the brachot -
gene which has been linked to breast
cancer so I know that I'm going to get a
lot of pace in the system so we specify
the genetic mutation and this very
special format it's actually not that
special if you're in genetics will
recognize the format from other tools
but if you're noting genetics it's still
pretty easy to explain as I'm sure most
of you know from high school biology you
can imagine DNA as a string of letters a
very long string of letters about 3
billion of those per person and there's
only so many letters in the alphabet of
this drink or basis and you might
remember a letters ACGT
sort of the main basis picturing here so
to specify a genetic mutation I need to
say where in this long string it is and
what the actual change of the letters is
and that's what I'm specify
here now because DNA is such a long
string we typically divide it into
smaller more manageable chunks like
chromosomes or genes and this brings us
to the query so the first number here is
actually a chromosome identifier and
humans have 23 pairs of chromosomes so
this would be number 1 to 22 or X or Y
and there's actually a few more options
because there's things like
mitochondrial DNA but let's not get into
these details the second number here is
the position within the region within
the chromosome so this would be a number
between 1 and let's say 260 million
depending on the chromosome different
chromosomes have different sizes so this
gives us the location now we need to
specify the actual letter and because
I've given the exact position
technically all I need to do is specify
that one letter or a group of letters
that's in that position in this case I'm
actually specifying a div so in this
case I'm saying a healthy individual
would have on chromosome 15 position 32
million something a letter G but I'm
looking for an individual that has a
letter C there and there are a couple of
reasons why this is specified as a div
basically it allows us to better capture
more complicated mutations for example
when a really large string gets inserted
to a certain position which would
effectively offset everything else but
it's also a very common optimization you
know we're all humans we're all the same
species so after the three billion
letters the vast majority of them would
be the same for all of us so in practice
quite often you don't actually need to
store all of them you might just want to
store a difference over some sort of a
reference genome and that's what's
happening here
so the first toggle at the beginning is
actually the reference genome identifier
so I've specified the mutation I'm going
to click search and what happens here is
the search engine takes the query it
processes it it talks to a bunch of
services a bunch of resources of genetic
information on the web and it a great
the responses so there's quite a lot of
data going on here we have a lot of
organizations really large research
institutions institutions like Wellcome
Trust Sanger Institute or the Broad
Institute as well as large data
aggregators such as Google and for some
of them they only tell you okay I have
seen this mutation before and if you
want to know more you need to contact me
in some cases they actually show more
metadata
for example here and that gets sort of
nicely parsed and sometimes they just
tell you okay here's some information
but if you want to know more you need to
go to this external system which
typically would be behind an
authentication authorization server so
the important thing to note here is that
we don't impose any constraints on how
the data is accessed each of these
organizations is completely in charge of
what they expose so sometimes the data
might be completely public sometimes you
might need to log into our system maybe
you need to be verified as a bonafide
researcher sometimes if it's really
sensitive data you may need to go
through like a full scientific and
ethics review by the data access
committee the point is that it really
depends and it's really up to the
individual institutions our approach is
basically show you as much information
as we can and ideally either link you to
an external system or give you some
contact information where you can find
out more that's pretty much all there is
to it there's a few more things that you
can do with the system but this really
is the meat and potatoes so going back
to my slides you can see that the beacon
network is basically a federated
aggregator right so why is such a thing
even needed well this is what the world
looks like right now the cost of genome
sequencing has been going down
dramatically
he decreased over 1 million times in the
last few years you can now obtain
genetic information for a person for
less than a thousand dollars and
machines capable of doing this for less
than hundred dollars are expected in the
next few years so a drastic decrease in
sequencing cost and maybe unsurprisingly
this led to an explosion of genetic data
the total amount of sequence data is
doubling approximately every seven
months beating the Moore's law so if the
growth continues of the current rate
we're expecting that we reach 1x the
base of sequence per year in the next
few years and once at the base in the
next ten years so in practice this means
that we're looking at tens of millions
of genomes from large sequencing
projects in the next two years or so and
we're looking at about 100 million up to
2 billion people sequenced in the next
10 years so that's a huge increase what
does it mean well we have a couple of
problems right we have too much data for
any single institution to handle
basically so the traditional approach of
aggregating everything in a single
centralized site which is how things
have been done until now it basically
doesn't work anymore and there's all the
fragmentation in aspect as well the data
is siloed it's often split by by a
disease or by an institution by a
country and it can really be shared
easily because there's regulations in
place or just incompatibility of methods
and tools secondly we still don't have
enough data to make new discoveries we
need more and the key obstacle is really
finding additional patients discovering
the new affected families so it's pretty
clear that the Federated system capable
of executing queries across data sets
across institutions that's the missing
piece here and that's exactly what the
beacon network is trying to pioneer so
the beacon network is called the beacon
Network because it connects all these
services and these services individually
are called beacons and this term comes
from a Jay 4gh initiative that was
called the beacon project it's something
that started back in 2014
basically ga4gh recognized that data
sharing is the key and data sharing is
needed but they didn't know if the world
was ready to share data so the premise
for the beacon project was basically to
just test willingness of organizations
to share and this came in the form of a
proposal for this simple web service
that you can implement I exposes some
information about your database of
genetic data so the proposal goes like
this create a simple web service that
accepts a question of the form do you
have any information about this mutation
and responds with yes or no so it's
really very simple there's literally one
bit of information that it exposes and
that was kind of the goal and later once
people bought into this we actually
extended this you can now expose things
like allele frequency or number of
matches or arbitrary key value pairs but
the simplicity in the initial design was
absolutely crucial to the other option
of the project and there were actually
three design principles that kind of
supported simplicity from several
different angles
first of all beacon had to be
technically simple remember this was an
experiment right if it was expensive to
implement order it require too much work
nobody would participate in this
experiment and we're dealing with
research institutions here right not
software shops
so technically simple means actually
really really simple a beacon also had
to minimize risks associated with
genetic data sharing so the idea was to
expose so little information that one
bit that nobody would think that
violates anyone's privacy and is
actually turned out not to be the case
it turned out that that one bit is
actually still too much for certain
things but that's a conversation for
another time and it also had to be
possible to make beacons publicly
available public is obviously the most
open form of data sharing which is very
good but it also means that you don't
need to deal with things like
authentication or authorization which
makes it even easier to implement so
like I said je furt which was the
standards body so in the last four years
this went basically from an idea to
pretty mature standard so let's briefly
take a look at this journey when they
first introduced the beacon network
which was back in 2014 there was
basically no formal API specification
all we had was this one sentence
description this is the question and
this is the answer and you might think
it's such a simple API surely everybody
is going to implement it well well it
turned out that wasn't the case when
engine when we introduced the beacon
network there were four beacons at the
time and they have completely different
IP is one of them was using JSON one of
them was using XML then we had plain
text and HTML they were using different
request methods completely different
parameters different notations different
domains for the same parameters it was
just a mess also when you created a new
beacon there was no sort of automated
process of registration you basically
had to email ga4gh and tell them hey I
have this beacon here can you add it to
your website and somebody would manually
go and add this sort of freeform text to
the website so each beacon would have a
section like this where they would
describe how a particular beacon is
queried and so on so forth so it
basically didn't scale and as a consumer
of this API you were in the turbo
situation if you wanted to find out if
anybody has seen your gentle mutation
you would have to go to this page read
it all understand it and then write a
script that actually talks to all these
services deals with all the API nuances
and somehow extract some Innokin
meaningful information from this and
that'll actually have the beacon network
started it was just a bunch of
converters between all these different
API is accessible
a single place on the internet so we can
network unify the API to some extent
which led to the first version of the
standard version 0.1 and the end of 2014
the first specification was really
simple what you're seeing on the right
is actually not an extract that's the
whole specification so there was a very
simple boolean response just ran false
it was written in Apache ro which is an
open source data serialization system
basically it comes with this interface
definition language every ydl where you
specify your schemas and protocols and
then you can compile them to a data
model in various programming languages
so it's pretty good for this sort of
thing where you need you know platform
independence and and such the
specification certainly was a step in
the right direction but it shared many
of the disadvantages of the original
beacon definition specifically it was
too vague
we basically defined the data model but
we didn't say how it maps to the
endpoints we didn't say what kind of
output format you should use we didn't
say we didn't clarify the domain of the
individual parameters so it was still
really vague and that was the problem in
adoption so I thought okay fair enough
we learn the lesson so year later we
came up with version 0.2 now we added a
few interesting features to the API
weighted support for data sets as means
of organizing our data data as
conditions so you could say things like
this data can only be used for research
or in this country which is quite common
with this kind of data we also added new
response types
aside from true and false you could now
say overlap and now which allows us to
better capture insertions and deletions
in retrospect this actually turned out
to be a very bad design decision because
not many people are actually dealing
with insertions intuitions and it turned
out that the reason people were buying
into this was the simplicity and they
really liked the fact that they could
say that this is a service that responds
yes or no so now that this was no longer
true that was actually a surprisingly
big obstacle maybe more importantly we
were painfully aware of the vagueness of
the previous version of the
specification being kind of the reason
why this didn't get adopted so we tried
to compensate for that and in a way we
went overboard and tried to over
prescribe everything so it actually led
to a very complex protocol which
in turn also cause problems in adoption
an interesting fact is that around sixty
beacons were created during the course
of 0.2 but strictly speaking only one of
them was compatible with the spec so
everybody else decided to diverge from
the specification for various pragmatic
reasons which is an API designer that
tells you the this tells you that you
basically develop the standard that
doesn't match real needs at all which is
a problem so we fought fine
lesson learned let's try again here
after that and with this release we
really took a step back and we basically
decided to break backwards compatibility
in favor of creating really nice stable
eight API as a basis for potential
future stable release we got the right
people involved and we really focused on
simplifying everything we focus on
modularity and extensibility so that we
can involve the protocol later on and we
focused on development of supporting
tooling so this was the first time that
we had things like a reference
implementation or a compliance suite SDK
CLI is various data adapters for various
data sources so we basically tried to
make it really easy for people to create
new beacons that would be compatible
with the specification and we actually
really got it right this was a very
successful release and very positive
adoption we also decided to switch away
from a pro hit we hit some of its
limitations and went to protocol buffers
so now earlier this year we came up with
open four and we added a few things like
support for more complex mutations but
basically we just focused on polishing
existing things to really just bring us
closer to the stable API we switch to
the furred format open API because
basically nobody was happy with that
Rover protocol buffers people find it
hard to work with and so far we've been
super happy it was really the right call
and finally this brings us to 1.0 so
during this year 0.4 was promoted
through a series of patch releases to
1.0 which is now ready in the sense that
it's on github well it's actually in
that final phase of the official ga4gh
standards review and approval process so
it hasn't been approved yet but it is
something that we're hoping to announce
next week actually in Basel Switzerland
which is the annual ga4gh poetry meeting
so we're really close and it's a really
exciting milestone for genetic data
sharing and religious the common
culmination of the f
of so many people over so many years so
really excited about that so that's the
standard let's talk about the search
engine build on top of it this is what
the system looks like it's structurally
it's a collection of nine subsystems 18
modules total it's pretty standard
technology stack old school if anything
it's using Java II now Jakarta of course
JBoss technology stack well fayette
cetera it's running as a collection of
services in doctor and kubernetes what
isn't nowadays so let's take a look at
the individual subsystems and see how
this fits together and what they do so
the data subsystem is actually pretty
easy to explain it basically takes care
of data access in our case this is a
relational database my sequel access for
JP a the service subsystem is sort of
the core of the whole system it takes
care of communication between all the
other components and it takes care of
things like query normalization
basically we support several different
notations in several different
conventions as inputs things that people
are used to from other tools but
internally we convert everything into a
single canonical representation the
service also deals with aggregators we
have this concept of a virtual beacons
which are basically they're basically
virtual services that from the outside
they behave as individual because they
give you the right response but
internally they're actually proxying to
a group of beacons so when they receive
a query they distribute it to all these
beacons and then aggregating a single
response so in practice basically you
end up with this directed acyclic graph
of beacons because it's many to many
relationship parents can have multiple
children and children can multiple
parents so this brings us the
participant resolution whenever the
service receives a query it basically
performs a breadth-first search on the
directed graph and it comes up with the
minimum list of services that you need
to talk to to be able to answer a query
so it accounts for things like
aggregators and caching and gives you
like the bare minimum of network calls
that you need to execute so this is
actually quite a significant
optimization for us and it really helped
us get the response times down
it also takes care of query distribution
this is basically level one
parallelization in the system kind of
across all the beacons so service
paralyzes across beacons processor takes
care of an execution of a query against
a single beacon and it does that by
running this four stage
execution pipeline basically the problem
that we had was that there were so many
differences between different api's that
static configuration wasn't cutting it
anymore
we needed something more dynamic
something more easily extensible
something more flexible so we were
looking for a way to store business
logic in the database in some way and
this is what we came up with so is this
four stage pipeline that that's drafted
individually for each beacon whenever a
query is received depending on the query
and the four stages are represented by a
converter a requester a fetcher and the
parser these are implemented essentially
as arbitrary Java classes so there's
maximum flexibility there's just a Java
code each of these components is an
interface
so there would be a convertor interface
a fetcher interface and so on all the
implementations would implement of
interface they're kind of like
functional interfaces in Java but not
really
they're basically functional interfaces
with support for generics and support
for Java EE so they would be implemented
as CDI beans or HIVs depending on what's
needed so when a processor receives a
query it basically reaches into the
database fetches the definition of the
pipeline then resolves the classes
dynamically load stem compiles the
pipeline and runs it so this is done in
case of CDI beans
this is lookup by the class name and
then you see the i-beam manager to
instantiate it in the case of ejbs this
is a simple chandi I look up so this is
sort of level two parallelization
sometimes you might need multiple
queries against the single beacon to
answer a single peak query in the beacon
network so let's take a look at the
execution pipeline the first stage is
the converter the converter basically
takes care of translating parameters
from the internal canonical
representation to whatever language a
particular beacon speaks so there are
five types of these for the main five
parameters in the query and just to give
you a sense of like the scale of
differences that we have here
we have 15 converter implementations as
CDI beans the second stage is the
requestor the requestor takes the
parameters from the converter it takes
the URL and it constructs a request that
needs to be sent to a particular beacon
and we have 11 requesters again
implemented a CDI beans the first stage
is the fetcher so the fetcher is the
unit that actually talks to beacon the
unit that talks to an external service
so it takes the request from the
requester it executes the network all
deals with networking errors etc and
obtains the raw response and we have two
implementations of these both over HTTP
ejbs so once the raw response is
received it goes to the parser which is
the final stage in the pipeline and
parsers basically take care of
extracting information of interest from
the response so they deal with things
like there is data formats JSON XML
string HTML they deal with different
fields in the response they normalize
the values they deal with parsing errors
that sort of thing so this is sort of
level 3 parallelization and we have 18
parsers implemented as SVG bees again
there's also a fin mapper layer which
basically takes care of translating
between different representations of
objects and there's also a very thin
rest layer which is basically api
gateway so it's the part of the system
that interfaces with the outside world
and deals with the client request we
have two AP is legacy XML and JSON and
aside from supporting all the
functionality of the network we also
wrap each individual beacon and like a
compatible full-featured unified beacon
API so you can actually submit standard
beacon queries against the network and
this is actually quite challenging
especially when it comes to supporting
very first beacons that didn't conform
to any specification and of course gets
more and more challenging as the API is
evolving but so far we've been
successful at kind of backward
supporting any beacon that that's ever
been created so that's where we are so
we have this search engine right and it
goes beyond any single data set single
beacon single institution so it's kind
of in a unique position in that it has a
global view of what people are searching
for so it will be kind of a shame not to
do some
data science around it and I'm not a
data scientist but I did spend some time
crunching some numbers and I was
basically looking at the last year and a
half of usage data which is since the
last time we've done this kind of a
study and this is what I found out in
terms of the size of the network we
currently have over 100 beacons from 40
different institutions across 18
countries and all the continents
besides intact Antarctica obviously a
lot of genetic research going on there
and because of the way this is set up
it's actually really hard to estimate
how much data we're searching because
it's it's up to each individual
institution to control that right so
quite often they don't tell you the size
of their data set if I had to
extrapolate from the information that we
do have I would estimate that a full
search touches over 2 million samples
and over 2 billion genetic variants
where variants would be unique within a
data set but obviously have no way of
comparing uniqueness across different
data sets so that's a lot of data and I
think we can truly call this a global
system in terms of the actual user base
so far with that 16,000 unique users
from 140 countries so again pretty
global system maybe unsurprisingly most
traffic comes from the countries that
also host beacons that would be the case
of 8 countries in the top 10 list as for
the number of searches in its 4 years of
existence the system has served over 1
million searches we actually reach that
almost exactly a year ago so and that
was a big milestone for data sharing so
I like sharing that number there's sort
of steadily increasing traffic so right
now we're actually closer to 1.5 million
but 1 million is a nice number to share
and since you typically target multiple
beacons within a single query this
actually resulted in too close to 8
million queries being distributed
through the network so if you do the map
on this on average you're looking at
around 1,500 searches a day in peak
times as many as 85,000 which gives you
10 searches a minute on average in peak
times as many as 12 to 13 hundred so you
might be thinking 1,500 searches a day
that's not a lot and you're right you
probably work on a system that handles
more traffic but what makes it
interesting is that each individual
search
the touch is so much data right and this
is a very niche field so our user base
is very narrow it's essentially
geneticists and mathematicians so this
usage is actually huge and remember that
the whole system started as an
experiment I think with these kind of
numbers we can safely say that the
experiment has been validated and has
been a success and people are ready to
share data so let's get the big deeper
and let's take a look at what kind of
information people are searching for and
we can do this sort of by different
parameters in the query the first one is
the reference genome and that's actually
a pretty boring one because there's only
five of these that the system supports
and grch37 is by far the most popular
one and that's actually not surprising
at all most beacons exposed grch37 data
it's also kind of the most common one in
terms of the data that I'm dealing with
on a day to day basis even though it's
not the latest one so this is actually
not a very surprising statistics we find
something a bit more surprising when we
take a look at the second parameter
which is a chromosome so in the chart
you see how many queries proportionally
targeted a given chromosome and you can
see that out of basically 25 options the
four most feared chromosomes cover more
than 1/2 of all the queries which is
statistically significant and if I have
to take a guess
before doing this analysis what the
distribution would be like I would
probably expect chromosome number 1 to
be in the first place
because it's the largest human
chromosome it's almost 8 percent of our
DNA it's very chin dance over 3,000
genes associated with over 350 diseases
so you would expect it to be up there so
it's it's kind of I mean it's definitely
up there it's in the top 3 but it's kind
of interesting to see that it's not in
the first place chromosome 2 which
claimed the first spot actually also
kind of makes sense because it's the
second largest chromosome again almost 8
percent of our DNA very chin dance
over 1,000 genes so it might be
interesting that it's number one but you
would definitely expect it to be up
there what's really surprising to me is
seeing chromosome 17 in the second spot
because 17 is a pretty short one it's
about freetime shorter than the largest
chromosomes it's not very gene dance so
it's actually very interesting that this
is so heavily studied
so let's take it a bit further and let's
take a look at the searches as a whole
and what kind of variants they target so
in total all our searches covered 85,000
variants distinct variants which might
seem like a lot but if you think about
how much variation that is that's
actually not that much it's actually
pretty focused search so again people
study similar things and in fact if you
take a look at the chart the top 10
variants cover over a quarter of all the
searches which is definitely very
significant and some of them even fall
into the same gene so that's interesting
so now that we have the variance we can
take a look at some of their properties
and one interesting property to look
into would be harmfulness basically you
want to see how many of these variants
are known to be involved in diseases and
obviously what you want to see is a high
number of damaging variants because that
kind of validates the system as a
discovery engine it suggests that people
are looking for stuff that they probably
have seen in their own data set and they
want to see who else has seen this
particular damaging mutation so how do
you determine if a variant is damaging
well you can do it experimentally which
is very accurate but doesn't scale this
mount or you can do it algorithmically
there are prediction algorithms
available that basically rank variants
in terms of their potential for being
harmful and they're not completely
accurate but it's a reasonable
approximation they typically look at
different things as as the basis for
their ranking so it's actually pretty
good advice to run multiple algorithms
you were trying to classify something
and that's what I've done in this case
so I looked at two really common sort of
classic benchmarking algorithms sift and
polyphen - and I ran them across all our
searches there's actually two versions
of polyphen - there's HD of an H bar
which are suitable for different types
of datasets but because beacon network
is a mixture of all the data size I
actually ran both and they got pretty
similar results so I'm only listing one
of them here but the interesting thing
is that safe things 69% of our variants
are damaging and polyphen things that
55% of our variants are damaging which
is quite a high number even if this was
like 10 percent I would say that's
pretty high so 55 and 69 is definitely a
very positive result
so whatever properties of variance can
we study well one thing that was an
important consideration for us when we
were designing that the system was it's
used for rare diseases we've come in
variants quite often you can find
additional information in various public
databases but with rare variants finding
that extra mesh that's really critical
because too many discoveries you need to
have some data to compare against so an
interesting metric for us would be how
many of these variants are actually rare
so how do you determine that the variant
is rare well one way to do this is to
basically take the very end and take a
look at its allele frequency in some
really well-known large data set and
that's what we've done here so we took
the thousand genomes dataset which is a
very famous public sort of reference
dataset for genomic studies and we
cross-referenced all our variants and
compute the allele frequencies in this
dataset a rare variant is typically
defined as a variant that has a little
frequency less than 5% so in our case it
actually turns out that 25% of variants
could be described as rare which again
is quite a lot normally you would have
let's say 1 to 4 percent of rare
variants in an genome so 25% it's quite
high it's a very interesting result so
ok we took a look at variants how can we
push this even further well one thing to
look into would be cross-referencing
variants with genes genes prescribe how
proteins are made so they determine
traits so that's a very interesting
thing to look into
so what done exactly that we've
cross-referenced our data set with the
gene database and we try to count the
number of genes that we've hit so in
total our searches hit almost 10,000
genes which is actually a lot but if you
take a look at the chart top 10 genes
cover almost 50% of all the queries so
again there's a small number of things
that are very heavily studied and I
don't actually have a lot to say about
these genes I can recognize many of them
but you can see that they're associated
with things like breast cancer
pancreatic cancer liver disease that
sort of thing so we can take this even
further right we have variants we kind
of extrapolated to two genes now we can
extrapolate from genes to the actual
diseases and
can take a look at what kind of
conditions people study and that's what
we've done here so we took a look at two
sources of data there's a meme which is
basically a catalog of gene to disease
associations one one problem with Oh
meme is that it doesn't use a controlled
vocabulary so we were doing some sort of
programmatic processing it's hard to
deal with things like synonyms which is
which is why people are increasingly
turning towards oncology's and one
really famous ontology is HBO so HBO
doesn't deal directly with diseases it
deals with clinical abnormalities which
means that you can have things that are
associated with diseases but that's
interesting as well so in terms of
diseases in the left column you can see
that people are heavily searching for
cancers there's pancreatic cancer breast
cancer prostate cancer and that's
interesting to know as for HBO rows 1 2
& 7 are not actual conditions they are
known they're basically what's called
modes of inheritance so there are terms
that describe how certain things are
inherited and of course everything is
inherited so we do expect these terms to
have many hits as for the other stuff
you can see that our issues associated
with spine height weight cognitive
defects birthmarks that sort of thing so
it's interesting to know what people
around the world study so that's all I
had for you today everything that I
talked about is open source and on
github it's easy to find just search for
ga4gh like I said it's a nonprofit
organization largely driven by
volunteering work so if you think that
this is something you would like to be
involved in definitely feel free to
reach out to me and I can get you
involved in this project or point you to
right people who are involved in other
projects and there's tons of exciting
stuff going on within ga4gh if you have
any questions I'll be around for a while
so just come up and say hi and otherwise
I hope you thought this was interesting
and enjoyed the last few hours of
strange loop
you